Hast du darauf geachtet, wie viele Meilen da hat? Nee, da auch nicht, aber in Überheit möchte ich, dass ich GPS habe, dass ich einigermaßen eine coole Karologie habe. Aber wenn du heute eh kommst, ist ja eh ein Auto. Aber nee, weisst du, der Mustang hat sich auch ganz angefühlt so und man könnte dazu damit fahren. Wo kannst du denn heute noch ballern? Weisst du, ich habe 140 Pferde unter der Haube, aber wann kann ich die mal rauslassen, wann kann ich die mal Gasse gehen lassen? Halte sie über 50, Zone 50, Spielstrasse. Alter, ey, diesen ganzen Zebrastreifen, wo du anhalten musst. Ey, es kotzt mich so an, da kommt jemand aus 20 Meter noch angerannt, ich muss anhalten, ja lass mich schön aufröhren und dann für den Weg krieg ich auch noch einen Vogel. Alter, ich bin der lauteste Autofahrer, ich berege mich gerne auf und laut und werde laut und ich hasse andere Menschen. Weißt du, auf der Straße bin ich ein anderer Mensch. Da werde ich einfach zu so einem Hassmenschen, so einem, ich kann dann auch, ich bin ungefiltert, lasse ich alles raus. Ich bin eher sozialisiert im Auto. Bei mir ist die Pferderennbahn, ey, wenn du mich einmal auf der Pferderennbahn erlebst, Alter, ich gehe aus meiner Haut. War unangenehm, wir sindhm. Seitdem haben wir auch Haus verboten, Pferderennbahn verboten. Naja, und dann war ich neulich an der Ampel und das Schlimmste, mein grösses Hassobjekt, sind Linksabbieger. Weil Linksabbieger ist erstens nervig, wenn du selbst abbiegen musst, ist es nervig. Wo willst du hin? Mal ganz ehrlich, wo willst du hin? Tatsächlich spart Zeit, wenn man nur rechts abbiegen würde und dann so oft rechts abbiegen würde, dass man links rauskommt. Was ist denn links? Spart Zeit. Was ist denn links? Ist doch nur ein Konstrukt, ein menschengemachtes Konstrukt. Was ist denn so tolles? Naja, jedenfalls Linksabbieger. Und dann war ich halt an so einer Ampel, die war so überfüllt, dass uns Autos entgegenkamen. Es war halt nicht eine von diesen coolen Ampeln, wo man sofort den grünen Pfeil hat und direkt links abbiegen kann. Nein, es war eine, wo erst der Gegenverkehr kommt. Die Gegner kommen. Lass sie kommen, die fahren nicht an, der Formel fährt nicht an. Ich denke mir, was soll es noch grüner werden? So erlebt man mich dann. Und dann kommen die entgegen, und dann fährt einer drauf, dann kommen noch Leute entgegen, so viele Leute, es ist schon lange rot, einer hat es halt über die Ampel geschafft, fährt dann aber quasi im roten Zustand, dann noch über die Kreuzung, weil halt so viel Gegenverkehr kam. Und dann war vor mir einer, ich dachte mir, war schon so, mit der Hand an der Hupe, saß ich hinter ihm und er fährt, die Ampel wird grün und er fährt über links, bevor der Gegenverkehr angefahren ist. Alter. Und ich dachte mir, ja, das ist fürs Team, ey. Das hast du getan, für mich, für KST 200 hinter mir, für K93 hinter mir. Das hast du für uns alle getan. Für M-A-L, wo kommt er her? Wo ist M-A-L? Was soll das sein? Wo ist LOL, wo ist die Stadt LOL? Naja, jedenfalls, der ist sofort links abgebogen, dann konnte es der Gegenverkehr kommen und ich konnte schön nach vorne fahren. Ah, geil, ey, Mittelstreifen Stefan ist mein Lieblingsstreffer.blingsstreifen. Mittelstreifen Stefan ist einfach der Beste. Er zieht an, er hat Zug, er hat die Handbremse in der Hand, man weiß nicht warum, aber es ist ein Fallosymbol, er will was Dickes in der Hand haben, es geht im Grunde wiederum. Und damit herzlich willkommen zur 110 Polizei Folge. Steh geblieben, Hände hoch. Ich bin doch nur eine Folge. Sie sind verhaftet, alles was Sie sagen, können gegen Sie verwendet werden. Das ist falsches Deutsch, aber ich bin doch eigentlich nur eine Postkastrufe-Folge, 110, warum nehmen Sie mich fest? Sie sind zu lustig, zu schnell auf der Datenhighway unterwegs gewesen. Gehen Sie in die schwedischen Gardinen, aber flottiger Lottin. Aber das ist ja schon wirklich rechtskräftig, was die einem da sagen. Angenommen, die versprechen sich. Kann man dann nichts gegen einen verwenden vor Gericht oder wie läuft das dann? Hatte ich tatsächlich der allererste Sketch, den ich jemals eingereicht habe, damals noch bei die Unwahrscheinlichen Ereignisse im Leben von. Die von dir alle abgelehnt wurden. Alle abgelehnt, gnadenlos alle abgelehnt, erst bei der vierten Staffel konnte ich ein bisschen was unterbringen und da war mein Sketch war, Polizist erster Tag, halt so Hausstürmung, ja, irgendwie so Rookie halt so in letzter Reihe, Pistole in der Hand so nach oben, man kennt so die Beverly Hills Pose und alle so, hey, weißt du, dein erster Einsatz, da musst du durch, ganz ruhig, bleib an mir dran, wir gehen da jetzt rein, okay, wir wissen nicht, was passiert, denk an dein Training, es wird hart, aber behalt die Nerven, egal was passiert, behalt die Nerven. Und dann war der vorbei. Und dann kam es ja schon Werbung. Aber nach der Werbung geht man wieder in die Szene, wieder der Anführer sagt, okay, wir gehen da rein, Johnson, heute ist sein erster Tag, aber du packst das, okay, wir gehen rein auf drei, zwei, eins, so, und dann kommt erstmal recht viel Regieinweisung, weil der Rookie, um den es geht, sagt ab dann alles falsch. So, also, ne, der sagt dann nicht, der kommt dann rein und dann hat der Gangster so eine Waffe in der Hand, eine Pistole und dann sagt er, Waffel weg! Und sowas in der Richtung. Und dann sagt er, und dann soll er die Hände hochnehmen und dann sagt er, Hände, Hände, Hände, Hände hoch, Hände hoch, zum Beispiel, Hunde hoch. Und dann gehen die in die Küche und dann hat jemand ein Messer und dann sagt jemand, tu die, tu das, lass gut, tu die, und dann sagt er alles, leg mal das Mikrofon weg, ist gut. Ich muss mich setzen kurz. Es war ein anstrengender Tag für dich. Dann tut er alles, weil er hatte die Autorität, weil er Polizist ist und die Pistole. Aber die Gangster folgen ihm auch, weil er sagt Waffel weg und die tun dann die Waffe. Weil er abgelehnt. Flo Hunden hatte damals so ein eigenes Dokument, so ein eigenes Google Docs Dokument, was ich mir mal angelegt habe, weil, weißt du, die anderen waren so sauer. Und dann habe gemerkt, so auf unserem Schulhof wird der gemobbt, so von den anderen Autoren, die mobben den so und dann habe ich so ein kleines Dokument angelegt, ich weiß nicht, ob du das noch weißt. Der Kindertisch. Der Kindertisch. Wo ich dann so großen Comic-Sense bunten Buchstaben, Florentins Ideen draufgeschrieben habe. Und dann war so ein kleines, süsses Dokument, wo du dann deine Ideen reinschreiben konntest und dann dachtest du, du hast was zu tun, hast dich dann auch still dahingesetzt den ganzen Tag.
Jeden Tag in der Mittagspause durfte ich meine Ideen sagen. Aber ohne, dass es dir wehtut. Ja, jetzt, wo sind die ganzen Ideen? Ja, in diesem Dokument. Der nächste gute Arbeitssketsch nach Ausschauender Folge ist der Rookie-Polizist. Auf jeden Fall. Und dann habe ich tatsächlich ja Important Things von Dimitri Martin, die Fernsehsendung, die Dimitri Martin hat, einer der besten Stand-Up-Comedians ever, hat dann auch eine Fernsehserie eine Zeit lang. Und da gab es auch einen Sketch, der so ähnlich aufgebaut war, aber da war die Pointe anders. Ich dachte mir schon, als ich den gesehen habe, dachte ich mir, alter, entweder du hast wieder unbewusst geklaut, oder fucking Dimitri Martin, der beste Gagmeister der Welt, hat die gleiche Idee, wie ich es war. Das stimmt, das fällt mir gerade ein. Er hatte die Idee, wo er der Rookie war und dann geht er los, okay, ich gehe da jetzt rein, bricht die Tür auf, kommt jemand, er schießt ihn sofort, er schießt jeden im Raum und dann heißt es so, ah, war der falsche Raum. Ah ja ja. Tür Nummer 15. Aber er hat geschossen und so. Ja, er hat geschossen, ja. Aber Dimitri Maarten klaut, das ist mir auch schon häufiger aufgefallen. Von mir. Nee, von mir. Zum Beispiel habe ich nämlich mal den Witz gemacht im Autorenraum, da bin ich nämlich auf dem Klo gewesen, da haben wir so eine Himbeerseife gehabt. Da habe ich mir die Hände gewaschen und dann fiel mir dieser Witz ein, bin lachend zurückgelaufen in den Autorenraum und habe gesagt, Himbeerseife ist geil, es sei denn, du hast vorher Himbeer gegessen, dann ist Himbeerseife echt uncool, weil man das Gefühl hat, die Hände sind nicht sauber. Und diesen Witz hat er eins zu eins in einem Stand-up gemacht. Auch mit Himbeer? Nee, da war es irgendwie Pfirsich oder Mango oder sowas. Aber ich habe es mit meiner Seife gemacht, er mit seiner Seife. Ohne Scheiss, strange. Und Pete Holmes klaut auch von uns, von mir. Ich habe nämlich im Podcast-Ufo sogar diesen Witz gemacht über dieses Strassenschild mit den Steinen, die runterfallen. Ich habe gesagt, was soll man tun? Alle anderen Schilder liefern dann praktische Hinweise, was man tun soll, um diese Situation dann besser und sicherer zu durchleben, aber dieses Strassenschild, was willst du machen? Donkey Kong, willst du da durchfahren oder so, du hast keine Chance, du wirst tot, wenn dich den Felsen trifft. Und exakt das hat er in seiner Serie, die ich dann nachgeschaut habe. Crashing. Crashing, weil sich als Stand-Upper irgendwie in der siebten, sechsten Folge hat er diesen Gag. Exakt den gleichen. Unglaublich. Die hören beide, klauen die von einem. Ja, ist aber wirklich so. Was hat letztens auch jemand gemacht? Es gibt, irgendeine Idee von uns wurde auch geklaut. Ich weiß nicht mehr genau welche, aber es ist immer so, ich habe auch das Gefühl, die Masse im Internet hat großen Spaß daran, jedwede Form von Plagiat zu entlarven. Das ist wirklich, du kannst schreiben, hey Leute, schreibt uns euren Schüttelreim in die Kommentare und wir lesen ihn vor. Nichts. Hey Leute, wir haben eine Umfrage, was ist cooler? Als wo D2 oder C3PO? Nichts. Hey Leute, schickt uns noch ein Bild. Nichts. Aber sobald mal irgendjemand sagt, aber mehr auch nicht, wenn irgendwo steht in der Broschüre, hundert Mails, hey, die haben euer Gag geklaut, hundert. Es ist ein wahrscheinlich inhärent befriedigendes Gefühl, weil Gag, ist erst mal, du zeigst, dass du dich gut auskennst mit der Materie und bar, du hast jemanden dabei überführt, was Verbotenes zu tun.
Das heißt, das grösste Gefühl.
Und jetzt kommt die grosse Rechnung. Schreib mal alle mit. Hol mal kurz, auch du Flo.
Blanco, ich hab nur einen Blanco.
Ja, hol mal einen Blanco-Block, nee, kariert. Hol mal eure karierten Blöcke raus, Bleistift raus, Radiergummi und ich diktiere.
Ja.
Also, wie viele Internetseiten gibt es ungefähr?
260 Millionen. Timo? 260 Millionen. Ungefähr 260 Millionen. Mal, wie viele Ideen entstehen pro Tag ungefähr auf Webseiten? 60. Pro Tag? Auf jeder einzelnen Webseite? Nee, im Schnitt, im Schnitt im Internet. Auf allen Webseiten insgesamt. Wie viele entstehen im Schnitt auf Webseiten? 500.000. So, dann 260 Millionen mal 500.000.
Ja.
So, das macht mal der Wurzel aus Pi, aber das ist eine andere Sache, das geht zu weit für euch. Gleich, und das Ergebnis ist, das ist die Anzahl aller Ideen, die pro Tag im Internet auftauchen. Es ist vor allem pro Tag. Also das ist ja genau. Wie rechnet man das jetzt aus? Weil wir liefern ja eine Idee, sagen wir mal. Die Chance, dass sie geklaut ist, ist sehr gross. Ja, und die Chance, dass sie einzigartig ist, singt mit jedem Tag. Weil die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass dieselbe Idee nochmal gefunden wird, ist recht hoch. Ich habe ja letztens ein Lied komponiert, nämlich Da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da dieser einzelnen Akkorde und auch die Akkordfolge total hervorkommt. Ich denke, es ist unglaublich frustrierend, wenn du als Musiker ein Lied komponierst, eine Melodie irgendwie ba ba ba ba ba ba und du denkst dir, ey, das klingt cool und das schreibst du dann in einen Song und dann gehst du irgendwie zu X-Faktor, gewinnst, entstehen ein paar peinliche Videos und Jahre später kommt dann, hä, das haben die Beatles auf ihrem B-Album, irgendwie schon 1972, haben die ba ba da ba ba ba ba. Aber das ist ja eigentlich häufig so. Und dann denkst du dir, fuck, weil du kannst ... Weißt du dann nicht, hab ich's geklaut und alle denken, du hättest es geklaut, weil jeder kennt die Beatles. Hast du es unbewusst geklaut, wusstest du es noch nicht? Es gibt ein Video über Dieter Bohlen, der klaut, weil der hat ein ... Da war irgendwie bei DSDS, haben die mit VW kooperiert und so, dann hat VW ein Jubiläum gehabt und dann hat er mit allen DSDS, Top Ten oder so hat er dann ein Musikvideo gemacht für VW, Joyride,
ein Lied. Und
das ist einfach ein Eins-zu-eins,
ein Eins-zu-eins-Plagiat von
einem Lied von David Guetta.
Und das ist so spannend,
du legst die Waveform übereinander
und es ist exakt die gleiche Waveform.
Du hast andere Melodien,
er benutzt zum Beispiel, also während David Guetta dann eher Tast, um mal in Laien-Sprache zu sprechen, Tast nimmt die nahe beieinander liegen, also Töne, die ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba nahe beieinander liegen, nimmt Dieter Bohlen halt, um den Plagiat offensiv aus dem Weg zu gehen, so ba ba ba ba, das sind halt so seine Melodien, also mit grossen, mit Quaden drin, mit Septinen drin und so weiter. Und das ist echt mega spannend. Und wenn man das Lied wieder übereinander geht und in die gleiche Tonart transponiert, singt das sogar am Ende in so ein Duett, weil er immer in die Pausen reinkomponiert hat. Also wenn David Gatter eine Pause macht, spielt Dieter Bohlen, wenn Dieter Bohlen nicht spielt, singt David Gatter. Er hat es einfach versetzt. Einfach versetzt, exakt. Krass. Er macht einen Auftakt da und das ist halt normal so bei manchen Deutschen. Wie unfassbar frustrierend ist man, es gibt auch ein sehr cooles Video auf YouTube, das ist How I Accidentally Wrote The Office Theme Song, wo halt irgendwie so ein junger Musiker halt komponiert. Der komponiert halt so an seinem Klavier und dann so, ah okay, da ist was und er komponiert und ah, hier noch ein bisschen mehr und am Ende merkt, das ist das The Office-Intro. Einfach so, ich habe die ganze Zeit immer mehr so, ah, da ist noch was, vielleicht ein bisschen höher und dann am Ende, scheiße, es gibt schon. Einfach so, ich habe die ganze Zeit auf ein Ziel hingearbeitet. Aber das war in meiner Bandzeit damals auch so. Ich habe mein erstes Lied geschrieben, Pizzaman, das haben wir auch aufgespielt. Pizzaman, das ist heute ein Hit, lustiger Song. Pizzaman, bringt die Pizza, bringt die Pizza, weil er es kann, weil er es kann, weil er es er Pizzamann. Ich glaube, in Carmen kennen so ein paar Leute Pizzamann. Ist ein cooler, so ist ein catchy Song. Leider eins zu eins geklaut, also nicht eins zu eins, aber alle meine Bandkollegen gucken sich so ein und die mir, was ist passiert, was ist passiert, was habe ich gemacht, als ich die so vorgespielt habe, alle so, ja, es ist einfach Green Day. Mach mal Pizzamann. Ne, mach ich jetzt nicht. Ich will euch mal irgendwann eine Demo vor, die wir mal aufgenommen haben. Aber das ist auf jeden Fall etwas, was häufiger vorkommt, dass man unterbewusst klaut, weil man einfach gerade was gehört hat und so, dass irgendwo stecken geblieben ist. Unterbewusstsein ist was Spannendes, oder? Ist ja auch bei Filmen und so, ist ja auch ähnlich, dass irgendwie ähnliche Handlungen streng immer wieder vorkommen und da gibt es ja diese tollen Videos, die das irgendwie zusammenfügen. Ja, was ist Kreativität eigentlich? Steal like an Artist? Ja, mega spannend. Neue Sachen zusammenflicken, woher kommen Ideen her? Das Filterprinzip, wir sind grosse, grosse Filter. Und unten kommt raus alles aus unseren Einflüssen. Und damit meine ich nicht nur Filme, die wir gucken, sondern auch in welchen Räumen wir uns befinden, in welcher Stadt wir aufgewachsen sind, welche Bäume wir sehen. So alles ist in so einen großen Trichter gepasst und unten kommt das raus in Liedern oder in Gags oder so. Ich glaube, das Grundproblem ist so, warum machen wir das, was wir machen? Ich glaube, ein Teil natürlich ist auch Bewunderung für andere, die es schon gemacht haben. Zum Beispiel, wir schauen eine Serie wie Arrested Development und finden das geil und finden das cool. Und weil wir jetzt eine Art von Menschen sind, die das nicht nur konsumieren, sondern auch aus dem Genuss den Wunsch sagen, Alter, sowas will ich auch gerne mal machen, setzen wir uns hin und sagen, ich schreibe jetzt eine Serie, ich will auch mal sowas machen. Und zwangsläufig wirst du dich dabei ertappen, wie du Arrested Development nachschreibst oder dann eben den Dieter Bohlen machst und versuchst es gerade so zu tweaken, dass es nicht mehr, du machst dann, ich mach kein Voice-Over, ich mach so Texttafel.
Ich glaube, die besten Dinge sind ja eigentlich, nur ohne Scheiss, gutes Beispiel, die Star-Wars-Teed-Melodie.
Hört euch mal von Erich Korngold den Soundtrack zu King's Row an.
Ein grosses Vorbild von Don Williams. Es geht exakt so. Ba ba ba ba, ba ba ba, ba ba ba, ba ba ba, ba ba ba, das ist die Musik.
Und ich denke mir so, ey, das ist, vor allem du sitzt da davor und dann kommt halt diese Musik, ba ba ba ba, ba ba, ba ba ba ba und du sitzt davor so ba ba ba, weil du es einfach, du willst es einfach diesen Ton kommen hören. Der hat total viel, auch von Max Richter, die Planeten hat, hat er auch wahnsinnig viel geklaut, auch so diese ganzen Science-Wischen-Sagen. Ich glaube, du meinst Holst, Gustav Holst meinst du, glaube ich. Oh, jetzt, wir driften so auf in so ein Kultur-Tool. Oh, toll, von 120 PS zu Max Gold, toll!
Podcast-Ufo-Kulturtalk!
Naja, was ich sagen will, ist,
die Bewunderung hindert einen oft, dass man sagt,
Alter, ich finde Arrested Development geil, und dann
will man so eine Ähnlichkeit, will man auch so was machen,
aber dann macht man dasselbe, und dann denkt man sich,
Mann, wie kommen die auf die Ideen,
wie kann man was für dich Neues schaffen?
Was ich sagen will mit diesem Beispiel, die besten Dinge
sind, glaube ich, genauso entstanden.
Lass uns das nehmen, aber mit dem und dem.
Was ist das? Was ich sagen will mit diesem Beispiel, die besten Dinge sind, glaube ich, genauso entstanden. Lass uns das nehmen, aber mit dem und dem. Wo ich gerade Doktor Haus gucke. Nehmt Sherlock Holmes und nehmt eine Artserie. Was Neues. Und das ist doch immer so. Ich will Sherlock Holmes machen, aber nicht die x-te Sherlock-Colmes-Verfilmung. Aber die Idee ist jetzt auch schon verbrannt. Sherlock Holmes, aber als Ballonfahrer. Ja, jetzt musst du Doktor Haus nehmen. Jetzt musst du Doktor Haus als Ballonfahrer nehmen. Doktor Haus als Bestatter. Oh. Leute, das... Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, weg von der Tastatur! Weg von dem Ideenwühltisch! Weg von der Tastatur! Wir sind keine Ideen-Prostitution. Weg, das zurück jetzt her.
Das Podcast ist wie so ein Discounter für Ideen.
Wir schmeißen so hin und dann bauen wir so Wühltische.
Und ich sehe euch doch da mit euren Griffeln,
mit euren Wühlhänden, so grossen Einkaufstaschen.
Ihr wisst, dass ihr viel mitnehmen werdet.
Und dann so vor dem Wühltisch stehen sie da und dann steht er so umsonst und dann holen sie sich da ihre Sachen ab.
Ja, oder der MP3-Player läuft und die Kopfhörer sind gar nicht eingesteckt
und er liegt auf dem Bett und man selber ist irgendwie grad duschen gegangen
Vielen Dank. Stehen sie da und dann steht er so umsonst und holen sie sich da ihre Sachen ab. Ja, oder der MP3-Player läuft und die Kopfhörer sind gar nicht eingesteckt und er liegt auf dem Bett und man selber ist irgendwie grad duschen gegangen und wir laufen gerade auf dem Bett. Hey, hör uns weiter an! Ich nimm uns mit in die Dusche! Oder mach uns zumindest aus und hör dann weiter! Ach, mein Gott, was sind so... Wie viel glaubst du, hört jemand, selbst der uns komplett hört, wie viel hört er dann im Prinzip eigentlich? Boah, maximal 70 Prozent. Wobei ich, wenn ich Podcasts höre, im Auto höre ich sehr viel zu. Da höre ich wirklich, also wirklich, wenn du auf der Autobahn bist, kannst du gut zuhören. Dann würde ich sagen sogar so 95 Prozent. Aber wenn es zu Hause so rumliegt, dann geht man auch mal. Mittlerweile, weißt du was, es gibt so viele Serien, mittlerweile gucke ich eine Serie und gehe dann irgendwie mir ein Sandwich machen in die Küche und die Serie läuft und es läuft.
Ich gehe mir scheiß drauf, scheiß drauf. Und ich kann es nicht mehr raten, ich kann mir auch nicht mehr ertragen, dass es so ruhig ist in der Wohnung.
Jetzt seit Jeff nicht mehr da ist. Seit Jeff nicht mehr da ist. Er hat immer gesungen, es ist nicht mehr da. Man vermisst, man vermisst dieses leichte Rauschen von der Filternlage.
Nääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääääää Man verwisst dieses leichte Rauschen von der Filternlage. Tag und Nacht.
Das vermisst man.
Und irgendwann ist es nicht mehr da.
Das ist ein großes Problem tatsächlich für die Meerestiere, dass das Meer zu laut wird.
Das ist tatsächlich kein Witz.
Ja, ja, ja.
Das ist ein echtes Problem.
Du sagst es halt sehr emotional engagiert.
Das kann nicht nur so eine Weintraube haben.
Klar, das ist die ganzen Schiffe und die ganzen Tanker und die Transportschiffe, wo dein Busselbord aus China, das fliegt nicht einfach hierher, das wird gefahren auf so einem Schiff. Und dann die ganzen Delfine und die Wale so die ganze Zeit. Und dann Automaton, was in seinem fucking Paket auch noch angeht und dann und dann die Wale denken, ach, seid ihr völlig bescheuert jetzt, mir egal.
Haben Wale Ohren, keine Ahnung, die nehmen doch auch gar keine Schallwellen wahr. Wie denn, unter Wasser? Klar, die machen doch auch so, äh, äh, äh. Ja, ja, ja, aber das nehmen die anders wahr bestimmt. Ich weiß, wie Wale machen, die haben nochmal den vorbeirasenden Wal gemacht. Und unter Wasser, die sind ja wahnsinnig schnell unter Wasser. Aber die krasseste Haustier-Geschichte ist, meine Tante fährt in Urlaub drei Wochen lang, gibt die Katze meine andere Tante. Und am ersten Tag ist die Katze weg, weil meine Tante hat gesagt, du kannst sie einfach rauslassen, die findet schon wieder zurück. Meine andere Tante lässt die Katze raus, sie läuft weg. So, heißt, meine Tante ist ... Aber rennt wirklich weg. Tür auf und dann ... Weg. Heißt aber, meine Tante ist drei Wochen im Urlaub, fragt jeden Tag, wie geht es eigentlich der Katze. Meine andere Tante lügt drei Wochen lang am Stück, sucht verzweifelt mit Plakaten, mit Facebook, mit Video und so weiter. Leute aus Berlin melden sich, haben die eigentlich völligen Schaden, glauben die Katzen sind verband mit Wundertieren, wie sollen die nach Berlin kommen? Naja, und dann kommt meine Tante wieder, ist aufgelöst, meine kleine Cousine aufgelöst, alle sind total traurig, Katze ist weg, oh nein, einen Tag später kommt sie an. Was? Und zwar sind diese beiden Wohnungen mitten in Dortmund, in der Innenstadt, aber so bestimmt zehn Kilometer auseinander. Heißt, die Katze ist wahrscheinlich von Anfang an wieder in der anderen Wohnung, ist, obwohl die mit dem Auto dahin gebracht wurde, wusste sie, wo sie war und ist zurückgegangen. Wie zum Teufel ist das möglich? Und dann kann ich ja nicht einfach das ertragen. Da habe ich mich reingelesen. Wie funktionieren Katzen? Und tatsächlich können die einfach so gut hören, dass sie Karten erstellen, Hörbilder erstellen. Und es ist wohl so, dass sie sich zum Beispiel an Kirchtürmen oder an Kindern, die immer rufen oder an Autos, die sie kennen, die können sich so gut merken und können dann schätzen, wo sie zu Hause sind. Und wahrscheinlich, wenn so ein Kirchturm, den die hören, den die kennen, dann laufen die in die Richtung. Ja, aber die können auch sehen. Warum nutzen die nicht ihre Augen, um Karten zu erstellen? Das könnten die auch, aber die können halt noch, also die können besser hören, als sie sehen können. Und ihr Hörsinn ist besser mit dem Gehirn verbunden, um zu erstellen die Karten. Das ist abgefahren. Das ist mega abgefahren. Aber hat die böse Tante, nennen wir sie mal, die die Katze verschlampt hat, hat die denn der guten Tante auch gesagt, dass sie sie zwei Wochen angelogen hat oder hat sie gesagt, die ist gerade noch da, die war gerade noch da, ich drehe mich um und sie ist weg. Ich glaube, ich habe schon eine Ahnung, wie Modern Family entstanden ist. Manchmal wünscht man sich dann so Talking-Head-Interviews. Ich wüsste gerne alle Einzelheiten über diese Story, aber ich kann jetzt zu meiner Tante mit so einem Reporter-Mikrofon gehen. So, erzähl doch nochmal. Hast du es am Anfang an gesagt oder hast du es am Ende dazugegeben, dass du dir ans Ende gelogen hast? Aber die Frage ist, was wäre schlimm? Das ist halt so die klassische Frage, was ist schlimmer? Zu erfahren, deine Katze ist weg und du wurdest belogen, hattest aber einen guten Urlaub? Oder zu sagen, ah, die Katze ist weg, aber dafür hatte ich noch einen guten Urlaub. Aber sie ist schon lange weg und ist wahrscheinlich tot. Aber dann kam die einfach an und ist halt durch Dortmund zehn Kilometer gelaufen, was ich asemberaubend finde. Meine Tante glaubt jetzt, dass die Katze hochbegabt ist. Ich habe nachgelesen, weil ich dachte, na, wahrscheinlich nicht, ist einfach eine Katze. Katze sind crazy, Katze sind krass. Ja, meine Katze war ganz klein und die war immer sehr neugierig, aber hat sich niemand, ich glaube, ich habe es schon mal erzählt. Ist gestorben, ist gestorben. In deinen Armen. Welche Lebewesen sind schon mal gestorben in deinen Armen? Uh, ein Fisch und viele Ameisen. Und dein Zwillingsbruder. Der klackst so aus, wie du die nur umringt. Den ich erwirbt habe im Mutterleib, ja. Mit der Nabelschnur einmal so und dann zack erwirkt. Ist das strafbar? Weiß ich nicht. Wie viele Spermien sind wir? Also wie viel? Eins. Fünfzig Prozent. Was? Ach so. Ja, ich meine, also wie viel Spermien steckt noch in uns? Also wie viel sind wir noch? Glaubst du, angenommen, man hätte die Spermie großgezogen? Nur mal rein rein hypothetisch, wie wäre die, wäre die so wie ich? Ach, meinst du, wenn die jetzt alleine grossgezogen würde, nur deine Hälfte? Nur die Spermienhälfte, genau, wenn du die grossziehst. Glaubst du, die wäre ertragbar oder? Schwierig, glaube ich, glaube die sehr... Oder wäre die sehr männlich oder wäre die sehr weiblich? Sind denn eigentlich so Walspermien grösser? Also die einzelnen? Seitdem ich weiß, dass Giraffen auch nur sieben Halswirbel haben, glaube ich an Maßstäbe nicht mehr. Lächerlich. Ich stelle mir auch den Biologen vor. Schneidet sie auf. Sieben? Wollt ihr mich? Bitte was? Ich kündige aber sofort. Ich habe nicht mein Leben diesen langen Hälsen gewinnt mit sieben! Ich glaube, es hackt! Ist auch der, der herausgefunden hat, dass Fische keine Knochen, sondern Gräten haben. Und immer zuckt diese Krankenschwester, die nebenan das Büro hat, immer so zusammen, wenn er ruft. Und sie hört immer dann so Gräten! Und sie zuckt immer so zusammen im Ne dem. Tausend Füße haben zehn Füsse!
Ich glaube, es reicht jetzt mal! Scheiss Choleriker. Der hat aber immer die Arschkarte. Der sich zu viel von der Welt erhofft. Aber sie enttäuscht ihn immer wieder. Zeit ist relativ! Ich glaube, was ein Schwachsinn! Und schon haben wir eine neue Figur entwickelt und eine neue Serie. Wenn aber nicht unsere tollen Podcast-Ufo-Fans wieder schnell zu HBO huschen. Nee, wenn die sagen, es geklaut. Das habt ihr doch hier von, Kristall hat das doch mal erzählt, als er mal bei Dreiser zu Gast war. Bullshit. Ey, Comedypreis wird nicht mehr im Kolonium aufgezeichnet, sondern jetzt bei Brainpool drüben. Da müssen wir uns umstellen. Drüben. Ja, hier drüben. Cool. Bei Brainpool. Das sind wahnsinnig große Pupillen. Ey, ohne Scheiß. Was ist da los? Also, die Geschichte heute. Ich bin auch ein bisschen aufgeregt. Weil ich war gerade beim Augenarzt. Ich bin eher, ich bin heute eher gegangen. Ich wüsste nur, dass du beim Arzt warst. Ich war beim Augenarzt, wegen meines Flimmern.
Ah ja, die Flimmer-Storyline.
Und da haben die mir gesagt, sie können nicht mit dem Auto
kommen, weil wir ihnen Augentropfen geben,
haben aber nicht gesagt, dass ich lieber mit
einem anderen Menschen da hinkommen sollte. Also, bin ich
alleine. Moment mal, und du hast dein Boosted-Bot auf dem Rücken
und sagt, Fräulein, ich brauche kein Auto.
Das ist kein Auto. Nein, sie dürfen
auch nicht mit dem Boosted-Bot fahren.
Naja, und da bin ich mit dem Cartogon hingefahren, damit ich das verstehen lassen kann, bin reingegangen, alleine halt, weil ich dachte, ich werde schon hinhauen. Ich sitze halt im Badezimmer und dann plötzlich ruft jemand, Herr Tietze, und dann dachte ich, bin ich aufgestanden. Dann kam auch eine Frau rein, die dann alle, da sitzen so 20 Menschen in dem Badezimmer, die läuft zu mir mit so einem Pipetten-Ding, wo dann so Augentropfen drin waren und so ein Tuch. und kommt zu mir, drückt mich auf meinen Stuhl, ich habe so eine Zeitschrift in der Hand, weißt du, und dann hat die mir den Kopf nach hinten gedrückt, drückt mir so ein Watteding hin und macht mir dann Augentropfen rein.
und alle anderen gucken mich so an, ohne was zu sagen.
Sie kommt, er sagt mich gerade, ja, folgendes, um ihre Pupillen zu erweitern,
damit wir sie besser untersuchen lassen können, müssen wir jetzt ihnen Augen drauf machen. Nein, sie kommt rein, schmeißt meinen Kopf in den Nacken, vor allen anderen alle so,
what, was ist denn los, lassen sie ihre Zeitschrift fallen, nimmt meinen Kopf, macht Augentropfen rein und geht. Und ich so, oh, weil es hat massiv gebrannt und sitzt dann so im Badezimmer, oh, fuck. Ich habe wirklich laut Jesus gerufen, weil das so gebrannt hat und die so lange weg war. Und dann wollte ich, ich habe halb blind, Augen weg ätzend, Schaum kam so raus. Was ist denn hier los? Guck, blinzelt so, niemand mehr da. Nur noch die Leute, die mit mir im Badezimmer saßen, als wäre nichts gewesen, gucken sie wieder in ihre Zeitschriften. Und ich sitze da wirklich so schmerzverkrümmt. Was war das denn für eine Augenarztpraxis? Und dann irgendwann kam ich dran und dann haben die mich halt untersucht. Und dann hat die Ärzte mir gesagt, dass es die Pupillen größer macht. Ich soll keine Angst bekommen, wenn ich gleich den Spiegel mich angucke. Und ich konnte nichts mehr fixieren. Also ich konnte nicht mehr, mittlerweile kann ich wieder Dinge angucken. Also ich kann wieder scharf stellen. Ich kann wieder sehen. Genau, man konnte nicht scharf stellen und es ist alles viel zu hell, weil du halt so große schwarze Pupillen hast. Und dann hat sie mich untersucht und meinte, das wäre eine Augenmigräne. Keine Ahnung, was das ist. Dann war ich fertig und dann haben die mich weggeschickt. Und das ist das, was du hast? Augenmigräne. Das mit dem Flimmern. Ja, das wäre vom Gehirn. Wegen Stress. Ich denke, what? Das ist Stresskörper? Alter, ich gehe auf die 30 zu. Da, dann kommt Stress. Vor allem, ich denke mir, das du Stress und du so, ja, ich sollte wirklich ein bisschen zurückschrauben mit, ich sollte nicht, ja, ich mache weniger, auf jeden Fall. Haben Sie denn einen krassen Beruf? Sind Sie da doll unter Stress? Was machen Sie denn? Ich glaube, ich schaue nur noch vier Folgen Narkos jeden Tag. Sorry, ich mache ein bisschen weniger. Aber man hat auch viel Druck, man muss immer mit neuen Ideen um die Ecke kommen und die Ärzte noch so, ja, ja.
Naja, und dann haben die mich weggeschickt und dann dachte ich mir, what, erstens im Weiterzimmer haben die mich behandelt, ohne was zu sagen und sind dann wieder weggerannt. Und dann sagen die nicht, dass ich mit anderen Leuten hätte kommen sollen, weil ich war, also ich bin dann rausgegangen ins gleißende Sonnenlicht und ich konnte nicht gucken, weil wenn die Augen im Dunkeln werden dann dann die Pupillen größer, damit die Netzhaut mehr Licht abbekommt. So, aber wenn du, wenn das künstlich gemacht wird und du bei so einem Sonnenlicht trittst, ist es viel zu hell einfach. Und dann bin ich so, ich bin bestimmt eine halbe Stunde lang an der Hauswand, durch Köln gelaufen, an Hausfassaden. Ah, das ist nicht eine coole Sonnenbrille dabei. Nein, woher soll ich das wissen, dass die das damit machen? Und dann bin ich dann durch Köln gelaufen, zur nächsten Station, habe ich in irgendeine, ich schwör es euch, ich habe mich in irgendeine Bahn gesetzt, die ist Gott sei Dank am Neumarkt rausgekommen, wo ich ungefähr weiß, wie ich nach Hause komme. Aber holy shit, ey, ich habe nichts gesehen, alle haben mich anguckt und ich habe so riesen Pupillen, ich habe jetzt immer noch so große Pupillen. Tschüss, bist du Stefan Tietze? Ich weiß nicht, wer ich bin. Ich weiß nicht, wo ich bin. Wer fragt das? Und dann hatte ich halt diese Riesenpupillen. Passant mal an, was ist mit ihm denn eigentlich los? Hatte der Augenarzt einen weißen Kittel an? Nee, aber er war Gesichtstattur. Hat die Praxis sich bewegt, während du behandelt wurdest? Ja, in so einem Van, kleiner Van. Ey, das war so... Das ist der schlimmste Gedanke, den man haben kann, ist, das war kein Arzt. Es gibt einen Stand-Up-Bit von Nate Bergetzi, der hat eine ähnliche Story, weil der hat eine Augen-OP bekommen und auch der wurde allein gelassen und der hat dann gewartet auf seine Frau. Und der hat dann auch den Gag gemacht, dass es vielleicht keine richtige Arztpraxis war, die du gemacht hast, also er klaut offen sind ja auch von dir. Und er hat dann gesagt, ich wollte erst sagen, ich habe niemanden mitgebracht. Und dass der Arzt dann so etwas sagt wie, haben Sie es jemandem erzählt, dass hier sind? Haben Sie es jemandem erzählt? Das sind keine. Das ist lustig. Hört euch, guck dich an. The Stand-Ups auf Netflix. Sehr gut, ja. Da ist er der erste, der erste Folge. Nate Borghazi. Cooler Name. Wir haben heute Morgen ein bisschen Empfehlung raus. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Er war Augenarzt. Aber ganz kurz, das heißt seine Diagnose, das ist Augenmigräne, du hast, ich sag mal in der Allensprache übersetzt, deine Augen sind müde, sind müde Augen. Ich glaube, es ist sowas wie die Prellung. Man will nicht sagen, ihr wart komplett umsonst da, das heilt komplett automatisch, Pussis, du scheiss Pussy. Und das ist sowas, das ist Prellung ja übersetzt quasi, in Arztsprech. Und hast du jetzt irgendwelche Konsequenzen gezogen? Also, reduzierst du jetzt deinen ... Sie hat gefragt, machen sie Sport, hat sie noch gefragt. Sie hat gesagt, ja, ein bisschen, Krafttraining, hat sie dann gesagt. Und dann, ja, jetzt soll ich halt, ich soll jetzt ein bisschen zurückschalten, Gang. Noch kurz und beklagen, wie alt bist du? Ich habe auch gesagt, kann das denn was mit Bluthochdruck zu tun haben oder so? Ne, sie sind noch sehr jung. Kann das denn was mit irgendwie, weil ich habe auch manchmal Kopfschmerzen, ist das denn schlimm? Bringt das denn zusammen? Ja, aber die Wochen sind irgendwann gelangweilt von meinem Fall, dann habe ich auch gedacht, komm, ich gehe jetzt einfach raus, das ist auch scheinbar. Da hinten steht jemand, der hat drei Augen. Okay, Sie können gehen, danke, okay, Sie da, kommen Sie mal her.
Aber ohne Scheiß, was auch seltsam war in der Praxis, der Arzthelfer, also der, der vorne an der Rezeption sitzt und immer die Anrufe annimmt und allen sagt, okay, Sie haben Termin, bitte ins Wadenzimmer gehen, der war zwölf oder so, der war lächerlich jung, also der sah aus, der sah aus wie so ein, das war ein Junge, so, und der war zwölf Jahre alt. Der war nicht älter. Der sah aus wie zwölf, vierzehn maximal. Der war in keinem Alter, wo man eine Arztpraxis leiten sollte. Und das war der einzige da. Er und die Ärztin, das waren die Leute, die da waren. What? Und dann dachte ich mir auch, der nimmt alle Anrufe an. Und der hat auch mal eine Karte genommen und diesen magischen Schritt gezogen. Also crazy. Und die Arztpraxis hieß, kann man das sagen, Veni Vidi. Ich kam, ich sah, auf Latein. Bisschen unbefriedigend. Ich kam, ich sah, das muss reichen, ich ging. Ich kam, ich sah und dann verdammt nochmal war ich glücklich, weil das muss ja auch zum Leben reichen. Ein Kino ist einfach nur ein Widivizi. Du schaust und gewinnst. Aber du musst nicht kommen. Es ist auch sowas, wo man peinlich berührt ist, wenn man dann da arbeitet und dann sich melden muss, wenn jemand anruft, so bei der Praxis. Ja, hier ist hieß, Angstpraxis, Viniwiki, hieß, alles Praxis, äh, äh, äh, äh. Aber das stehe ich mir auch vor, so Hitler hat gerade Paris erobert und steht so vorm Eifelturm und sagt, wisst ihr was, Freunde, ich kam, ich sah, ich siegte. Die ganzen Offiziere schauen sich so ein bisschen peinlich an, so, gut, gut, gut gesagt, mein Führer, gut, cooler Spruch.
Die Würfel sind gefallen.
Und jemand so, okay, es reicht, es reicht.
Ein grosser Schritt für mich.
Oh, tatsächlich, tatsächlich sehr innovativ, neu, so noch nicht gehört, noch nicht.
Ah, sehr gut, einfach jemand, der offensichtlich glaubt und alle wissen es. Auch eine coole Figur, jetzt haben wir schon zwei Figuren. Am Ende der Folge steht eine neue Serie, eine neue Figurenkonstellation. Wir brauchen nur noch Gefühle. Oh, ich will mir entfühlen, oh, ich will auch was fühlen, oh, mein Herz ist so kalt und leer, oh, diese Serie soll mich erfüllen mit Emotionen, die ich im realen Leben nicht hinkriege, oh, mein Gott, stell dich mir so an, ey, nervig. Ich rede nur noch über Krankheiten, ist mir aufgefallen. In meinen letzten Bits waren alles Arztsachen. Weißt du, ich werde jetzt auch immer so ein Alter, wo ich langsam zerbreche, und da muss man auch mit klarkommen. Ich glaube, dein Leben wird halt so Tarantino-esk erzählt. Weißt du, so der Anfang am Anfang
und jetzt du bist schon am Ende, dann
kommt der Mittelteil, dann kommt noch mal
ein Flashback, dann am Ende und dann stirbst du,
aber die Story geht trotzdem weiter. Und du bist
jetzt schon so im Jahre 70er.
So wie Benjamin Button, was dann runtergefallen ist, die VHS
und dann muss man das neu zusammenschneiden und dann
nach, fuck it. Also so ein Roman, so Mängelexemplar-Roman,
wo man sich denkt so, der,
was ist da los? Hier fehlen ein paar Seiten. Was ist mit der Band? Der ist auf dem Mond, aber der ist doch acht Jahre alt. Was ist da los? Wie kann das sein? Ey, wenn wir diesen Podcast noch mit 70 machen, wenn das langsam auch so ein Privatgespräch wird und die Audience auch scheißegal werden, dann reden wir auch noch über Krankheiten. Ja, die Ruth, die hat neulich da, hat sie jetzt erzählt, hat mit ihren Händen angefangen zu zittern, die macht sich jetzt ganz tolle Sorgen wegen Parkinson.
Ja, die will ja jetzt sich digitalisieren lassen.
Ja?
Aber ich weiss nicht, das ist irgendwie ein unseriöser Anbieter.
Ich weiss nicht.
Von Mackeeper, der will die digitalisieren, weiss ich nicht.
Oh, da kommt gerade der Mars Rover vorbei und bringt das Essen. Wir melden uns dann nochmal.
Warum nennen wir den Mars Rover?
Okay, die Frieda und ich, die nennen wir, wir melden uns dann nochmal. Okay, die Frieda und ich, wir melden uns dann nochmal. Tschüss. Das sind die Podcastaufnahmen. Wir haben mit Skype verbunden, auf dem Mars, du wohnst irgendwo ganz weit weg, Alpha Centauri, wo es sich hinverschlagen hat. Schon cool. Ey, die Zukunft ist, glaube ich, ganz schön geil, aber ich stelle mir vor, wir werden ja dann rumfliegen, alle, werden wir rumfliegen in Raumschiffen, wie es jetzt Autos sind, klar, das ist logisch, aber es gibt dann auch Fahrlehrer, ich glaube, die Vorstellung ist geil, wir fahren alle wie Rebellen mit unseren eigenen Flugzeugen rum, natürlich gibt es auch Regeln, natürlich gibt es auch einen Fahrlehrer, der uns sagt, wo wir dann eine Prüfung machen müssen, der einen dann über die Brille so anguckt und sagt, ja, und jetzt ... Ja, klar, aber das ist ja dann die Zukunft, das heißt, er hat dann auch eine Space-Brille auf und auch so ein Space-Schnurrbar und greift dann der Schülerin unter den Space-Block. Jetzt gucken Sie bitte erstmal da hinten und dann können Sie losfahren. Mal einen Schulterblick. So, bevor wir losfahren, Freundchen ... Bevor wir losfliegen ... Erst mal den Cyber-Gurt anlegen. Ähm, okay, das ist hier, ä, das ist hier oben der Cybergurt. Das ist eine 260 kmh-Zone. Wir sind ja nicht auf der Flucht, Freundchen. Wir sind auf der Flucht und nicht auf der Arbeit. Hier nur doppelte Lichtgeschwindigkeit, Freundchen. Haben Sie das Schild nicht gesehen? So, und hier wäre jetzt rechts vor links gewesen. Hier, einmal ... Da kommen die ganze ... Da werden fast in die Plasma-Ione reingeflogen. Einmal in die achte Dimension abbiegen, bitte. Nee, in die achte. Jetzt müssen wir noch mal umwählen und noch New-Turn. Jetzt machen Sie den New-Turn, um hinten in den Hyperraum zu kommen. Machst du einmal bitte hier so links blinken. Wie lang ist der Bremsweg, wenn Sie sich mit 80-fachen Lichtgeschwindigkeiten bewegen? Weiß ich jetzt gerade nicht. Doppeltes Plasma entzündet sich bei Geschwindigkeiten von ... Das ist so kompliziert. Zu schwierig. Leute können das nicht mehr bedienen. Ich glaube, der Mensch wird nicht intelligenter, oder? Also der normale Mensch, der Plebus, der wird doch, also Wohlstand führt ja auch zu Dummheit einfach, wenn du dich nicht mehr selber erarbeiten musst, sondern alles für dich gemacht wird. Wir sind schon schlau. Ja, man ist schon schlau so, aber man ist auch dann, man ist auch faul und man ist auch vor allem, wenn man sich nicht, man will sich nur zu einem gewissen Maßen Dinge reinfuchsen. Also ich würde uns schon als intelligent bezeichnen, aber dann so manche Dinge, wo man, die man wissen sollte, wenn man sich so, wenn man sich so etikettiert, die weiss man einfach nicht. So, wir wissen nicht, wie manche Dinge funktionieren, wie ein Fernseher, so ein alter Röhrenfernseher funktioniert. Keine Ahnung. Irgendwas mit Spulen. Eine Hupe. Eine Hupe ist eine Spule, die immer an und aus geht und dadurch wird so ein Ding in Schwingung gebracht. Eine Hupe, die gemeinert, nee, Hu Aha. Siehste, wusstest du nicht. Und du bist
ein schlaues Individuum, aber das
weisst du nicht. Ich schaue gerade The Nick,
auch eine fehlenswerte Serie
aus dem um 1900 herum
um ein Krankenhaus mit Clive Owen.
Und da haben die auch einen
Krankenwagen, was halt eine Kutsche ist,
mit Pferden, und da haben die auch eine Sirene,
die muss man aber so mit der Hand drehen, so kurbeln.
So, ii, ii, ii, ii, muss man mit der Hand kurbeln die ganze Zeit.
Die Pferde machen lassen. Die ganze Zeit, aber ist nicht so. Und daneben sitzt da einer mit so einer Lampe, der immer an und aus macht, eine blaue Lampe.
Ja, es ist so ein bisschen, es ist ein bisschen frettfeuersteinig, finde ich so.
Man nimmt Dinge, die man kennt und überträgt sie dann so, weisst du, damals in der Steinzeit, ja, da haben die dann eine Steintafel angeguckt und dann hat jemand 24 Bilder pro Sekunde reingemeistet. Aber auf der anderen Seite, ein bisschen ist es ja so, dass wenn du so eine Krankenkutsche hast, da dreht dann jemand die Sirene. Aber woher willst du das wissen, dass es wirklich so war? Weißt du nicht. Briefe, ja. Ich finde, dass man mittlerweile weiß weiss, wie es war. Also man, also ab jetzt, gewisserweise seitdem es Bildschirme gibt und Fernsehen gibt und so, weiss man, wie Dinge waren. Und das ist doch cool zu wissen. Da ist eine andere Zeit angebrochen. Ich habe zum Beispiel, was so war, war, man kann ja die Sendungen angucken von 9-11, vor 9-11, am Tag. Und dann habe ich da neul neulich abends eine Sendung gesehen, wo das dann gezeigt wurde, ein Ausschnitt, wie ein Morningshow-Host an 9-11 sagt, oh, herzlich willkommen, schönen guten Morgen an diesem wunderschönen Dienstag, den 11. September 2001. Wow, New York ist ruhig, zu ruhig, na ja. Und ich denke mir so, what? Das hat er nicht, was?
Wie gut, ey, wie gut.
Ja, und das ist so,
wir wissen, dass es passiert.
Klar, jeden Morgen
haut irgendein Typ so einen Spruch raus, aber an dem
Morgen
New York ist ruhig, zu ruhig,
naja, kommen wir zum Wetter.
Fand ich sehr lustig.
Aber da gibt es dann auch so Verschwörungstheorien, wo dann so ganz verrückte Zufälle dann plötzlich sein, wo dann jemand sagt so, heute wird wohl kein Flugzeug in den Hocker-Kratzer fliegen.
Und dann schon später und alle so, was weißt du?
Und er so, es war nur ein Gag, es war nur ein Gag, Hilfe.
Aber irgendjemand hat den Gag gemacht, irgendjemand auf der Welt hat den Gag gemacht.
Vielen Dank. Es war nur ein Gag. Es war nur ein Gag. Hilfe. Aber irgendjemand hat den Gag gemacht. Irgendjemand auf der Welt hat den Gag gemacht. Hat er gesagt, hat er präzise gagig vorhergesagt. Eben, was mir neulich gar nicht so, danach, der Beitrag ging dann weiter, hat irgendwer gesagt, was man oft unterschätzt ist ja, dass er es mit den zwei Flugzeugen und den anderen Flugzeugen, die danach noch kamen, nur gemacht hat, auch zu der Uhrzeit, damit man das live sieht.
Und darüber habe ich mir noch gar nicht so viele Gedanken gemacht.
Klar hat man schon mal so drüber nachgedacht, aber wenn man sich das nochmal wirklich überlegt, da muss jemand gesessen haben und gesagt haben, gut, wann machen wir das? Morgen um acht Uhr, da gucken die meisten Menschen live Fernsehen. Dann lassen wir noch einen zeitversetzt reinfliegen mit dem späteren Flug um den um das weil die meisten Terroranschläge ist ein Problem von Terroranschlägen siehst du ja nicht dann schalten die Leute an und dann kommt ja und dann kommt das Flugzeug ja das heißt so viele Gedanken muss sich jemand gemacht haben what genial bleibt dabei ist wirklich genial bleibt dabei bis heute unangefochten Nummer eins der Wannschläge. Absolute number one, kommt keiner ran.
Zu ruhig.
Der beste PR-Stand.
Oh, langweiliger Tag heute, mal schauen, was noch so passiert.
Geht schon mal nach Hause, Freunde, heute brauchen wir die Kameras nicht mehr. Naja. Das ist schon lustig. Hallt wieder heute sehr, oder? Wir sind wieder in so einem ... Hall, hall, hall! Wir sind wieder in unserer Tropfsteinhöhle gelandet, in so einem grossen Saal, den wir manchmal als Rückzugsort nehmen. Wir werden echt vertrieben, ey, werden aber weiter vertrieben, werden hier rausgemobbt.
Hat so auch angefangen bei den Juden, haben die gemerkt, hm?
Sie kommen plötzlich nicht mehr in den Technikraum rein?
Sie kommen plötzlich, können sie nicht mehr in den Maskenraum aufnehmen.
Was ist denn jetzt hier los?
Sind das die ersten Anzeichen?
So, ach, in eurem Raum wird schon wieder gedreht.
Hm, ihr müsst ins Techniklager.
Mit dem Zug ins Techniklager. Mit dem Zug ins Techniklager.
Als ZDF-Projekten
würde das jetzt rausgeschnitten werden.
Sollten wir das ausschneiden?
Das würden sie vor allem
ausschneiden. Das würden sie ausschneiden.
Das Erste, was man zensiert, ist, dass man zensiert.
Das ist ja das Krasseste.
Ja, erzähl mir mal mehr davon.
Erzähl mir noch mehr davon. Naja, du willst denn, das ist schlimmer, als etwas zu sagen, was zensierungswürdig ist, ist es ja, der Zensur überführt zu sein. Ja. Zu sagen, ah, die zensieren. Das ist ja schlimmer, als wenn man sagt, ja, hier irgendwas, was man zensieren könnte.
Das war meine vollständige Ausführung zu dem Thema. Das war das Referat.
Dankeschön.
Danke.
Kann ich jetzt?
Ja.
Gibt es noch Fragen?
Ja, das mit dem Zensieren habe ich nicht ganz verstanden.
Mit dem Wie meinst du das?
Also wenn man zensiert, ist es schlimmer, als wenn man zensiert?
Wie gesagt, also jetzt zum Beispiel in einem autoritären Regime wurde ja auch zensiert, also Leute aus Fotos geshoppt, und da dürfte man auch nicht sagen, dass das gemacht wird. Also es war zensiert, die Zensur zu erwähnen. Ja, danke für Huntin, fürs Referat. Das Thema war ja eigentlich Hunde. Deswegen fragen wir uns jetzt hier alle in diesem Bio-Unterricht der achten Klasse, was das für ein Referat war. Aber trotzdem war nicht schlecht, die Folien waren ganz schön, die Animation waren ganz schön, du hast an die letzte Folie mit Danke für ihre Aufmerksamkeit gedacht, deswegen kriegst du eine drei Minus. Okay? Ich habe grossen Respekt für einen meiner ehemaligen Schulkollegen,
die ein Referat ...
Die Person hat vergessen, ein Referat vorzubereiten
und hat es trotzdem geheilt.
Karaoke.
Einfach fucking wing it.
Referat, karaoke.
Und es ging um Apartheid.
Und die Person wusste auch einfach nicht, was Apartheid bedeutet.
Ich finde, das ist so ein lustiges Wort.
Ja, heute geht's um Apartheid. Alle wissen jetzt schon, er hat nichts mehr bereit, aber er hat noch 15 Minuten to go. Und die Lehrerin denkt sich, alles klar, jetzt mach mal 15 Minuten Strecke, Kollege. Apartheid bedeutet, wenn in einer Gesellschaft, die man den, also wenn mehrere Menschen sich dazu entschliessen in, welches Fach ist das? Auch die Lehrerin dann so. Ach, und wann ist das ungefähr passiert? Und über dieser eine Mitschüler, der mitgeschrieben hat, das Referat, auch so Notizen gemacht hat, obwohl das gar nicht klausurrelevant war, der dann auch so Fragen gestellt hat zum Referat, wo man als Schüler dann auch denkt, ach komm, du nicht Sven. Einfach auch so gut, weil er hätte natürlich gesagt, wenn er sich vorbereitet, kriegt die Sex oder was weiß ich, Verspätung, aber er hat es einfach gesagt, genau wie Sexualkunde, wo es dann immer hieß, ja, jetzt geht es um ein gewisses Thema, da werden wir, Stefan, da gibt es keine Klausur zu dem Thema. Und erst mal die letzte Reihe steht geschlossen auf und geht. Denkt sie einfach so, was mir lieber, wissen wie der weibliche Körper funktioniert oder Playstation 2 zocken? Ist ja völlig klar. Aber ich habe jetzt gerade einen Flashback zum Sexualkundenunterricht,
wo wir so Holzpenisse
bekommen haben, wo wir dem ein Kondom überziehen mussten.
Das mussten wir nicht machen, in Bayern macht man das nicht.
Alter, was ein
Prügel stand da vor mir.
Das ist das eigentliche Problem.
Und alle sassen da und dachten so, das kann jetzt nicht.
Das kann jetzt nicht.
Nina?
Es ist tatsächlich gar kein so schlechter Einwand eigentlich, weil es ja tatsächlich auch für gerade pubertäre Jungen ein Thema ist. Und wenn man mal wirklich so einen Porno-Dengel dahinstellt, dann ist das ja natürlich auch wieder das Bild, dass man eigentlich in einem gesunden Sexualkundeunterricht gerade nicht rüberbringen kann. Man konnte dann auch Fragen ein, also dann haben wir so eine Runde gemacht, wo man anonyme Fragen ausschreiben konnte und die dann auch einreichen konnte. Und in der Handschrift hat der Lehrer natürlich die ganze Zeit K Klausuren von, war unser Klassenlehrer, war Bio- und Deutschlehrer, die ganzen Klausuren von uns, natürlich kennt er die Handschrift und Sagen so vorzuordnen. Und dann wirklich über 80% waren Penisgrösse Fragen, wo man auch denkt, ja, dann ändert vielleicht das an euer Unterricht, okay, dann ändert das ein Riesenpimmeln mit wirklich Durchmesser von auch zehn Zentimeter, so Dosengrösse, wo man auch denkt, Leute, das ist ja nicht mehr ernst. Aber ich habe, wo wir gerade über Referate gesprochen haben, es sind noch Referate von mir online. Und zwar Prezi. Hast du mal Prezi gemacht? Ja, habe ich auch mal gemacht, ja. Diese für die uncoolen Leute, die sich dann so ein bisschen zu sehr reinfuchsen ins Präsentationsgewerbe. Genau, wo dann immer auch so dann so bei Effie Bries wirbeln dann die einzelnen Figuren so rein. Und wie die reinwirbeln. Ja, und ich fand es cool, was überall lief. Ich hatte damals schon Mac und niemand anderes war kompatibel und so und das ging alles nicht. Und deswegen brezzi ist einfach überall diese Flash-Animation, das geht halt immer. Und da habe ich, da konnte man nur Striche machen und Kreise und so Formen halt. Und ich habe den Massenspektrografen, ich musste bei den Massenspektrografen in Physik ein Referat halten. Und ich habe nur mit verschiedenen farbigen Strichen einen Massenspektrograph 3D modelliert. Alter. Und es war so aufwendig. Und der ist so, ich habe das Referat auch furchtbar. Ich habe keine Ahnung, ich habe heute keine Ahnung, wie ein Massenspektorat funktioniert. Okay, die Elektronen sind unterschiedlich schwer und deswegen landen die überall
verschieden, weil die umgelenkt werden, blablabla.
Aber ich habe so Spaß daran gehabt,
dieses Massenspektorat zu bauen.
Und ihr findet auch noch ein NS-Referat.
Ein NS- und ein Massenspektorat-Referat.
So, jetzt sucht mal, Freunde. Jetzt gehen die Spürhunde
jetzt los. Ihr müsstet ihr bei Prezi finden.
Ich glaube, es ist eine öffentliche Präsentation.
Ansonsten riecht die mal raus und halt die nochmal hier im Podcast.
Nicht schlecht.
Damit wir alle mal was lernen hier.
Klar.
Nächste Woche bin ich ein Referat von dir.
Und ich mache Massenspektrograf und NS-Ideologie.
Mach ich Leibniz. Der leckerste Keks der Welt. Kekin! Bau, bau, bau, bau, schlechter Gag hat man von den Weiten hergerochen, den Keks.
Das ist ein Keks-Gag. Ach ja.
Ach, lass doch ein bisschen diesen Raum beschreiben, ichah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, boah, bo Stühle, einen Tisch und ein Sofa stehen. Ja. Wie lange haben wir noch, können wir? Ach ja, komm. Ich bin auch echt angeschlagen, ich habe eine stressige Woche vor mir, aber. Ey, weißt du was, mir hat heute auch eine Ärztin gesagt, schalt mal einen Gang zurück. Ey, und das machen wir heute. Und du musst auch mal einen Gang zurück schalten. Wir schalten heute mal einen Gang zurück und ihr schaltet auch mal einen Gang zurück. Ihr hört jetzt auf, erstell ich diese Podcasts zu hören. Wobei, wenn alle einen Gang zurückschalten, dann läuft die Welt nicht mehr. Das auch nicht. Also sagen wir mal, alle mit Nachnamen von A bis M schalten diese Woche mal einen Gang zurück, okay? Richtig. Und die anderen einen Gang nach vorne, L bis Z mal einen Gang nach, richtig mal reinbrennen. Also Monatsanfang, sagen wir mal bis zum 15. September, alle bis M schalten einen Gang zurück, dann umgekehrt, M bis Z schalten Gang zurück, wir schalten wieder Gang nach vorn, um dann wieder mit frischem Gas zu geben und ab dem 1. Oktober schalten wir wieder Gang zurück. Absolut, und dann ab 2018 erstmal parken. Erstmal parken und Leerlauf. Ja. Wofür steht das D eigentlich bei Automatikwagen? Drive. Das war's von mir.
Vielen Dank für diese Folge. Bis nächste Woche, wenn wir wieder Taten sehen.
Macht's gut, wir heben ab und sagen